الى الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله حيث
استشهد شاب فلسطيني واصيب ثلاثه بالرصاص
بينما اصيب 57 اخرون بحالات اختناق بسبب
قنابل الغاز المسلي للدموع خلال مواجهه مع
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه التي اقتحمت
الحيه الشرقي في مدينه نابلس فجر اليوم
العسكريه لحركه فتح ان الشهيد هو مهدي
حشاش وقتلته قوته الاحتلال خلال
اشتباكاتهم مسلحه ومواجهات دلعت على خلفيه
معلومات
في الكنيسه من الاحزاب بالمتطرفه اقتحامه
من طاقه قبر يوسف الواقعه في شرق مدينه
نابلس حيث يتوضا للقوات العسكريه وانتشر
القناصه في محيط المكان
من فلسطينيه ونشطون عبر منصات التواصل
مقاطع فيديو لمواجهه واشتباكات بين شبان
فلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال في منطقتنابلس
ليله الماضيه اللقطات المصوره تلك تظهر
لحظه وقوع اشتباكات في مناطق مختلفه
بمدينه نابلس اضافه الى سماع اصوات اطلاق
نار عاقب اقتحام قوات الاحتلال للمنطقه
ليلا كما تظهروا اللقطات المصوره لحظه
اطلاقه قوات الاحتلال الغاز المسيله
للدموع داخل احياء المدينه واعلنت مجموعه
عرين الاسود التصديا الاقتحام قوات
الاحتلال لمدينه نابلس والاشتراك معها
اعتقلت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اثنى عشر
فلسطينيا على الاقل في انحاء مختلفه من
بلدات وقرى الضفه الغربيه والقدس الليله
الماضيه وفجر اليوم وقد افدى نادي الاسير
الفلسطيني بان هذه الاعتقالات تركزت في كل
من قرى وبلده القدس والخليل وبيت لحم ورام
الله ونابلس وطول كرم حيث يقتحمت قوه
عسكريه هذه المناطق ودهمت عددا من المنازل
واقتدت المعتقلين الى مراكز للتحقيق معهم
بتهمه مقاومه الاحتلال
سلمت لجنه الانتخابات المركزيه
الاسرائيليه اليوم نتائج الانتخابات لرئيس
اسحاق هيرتسوج الذي سيبدا بعدها اجراء
مشاورات مع قاده الاحزاب الفائزه في
الانتخابات من اجل تكليف المرشح لتشكيل
الحكومه المقبله عصر اليوم يتوجه ممثلون
عن الاحزاب الفائزه في الانتخابات الى مقر
الرئيس في القدس الغربيه لتقديم توصيتهم
بشان مرشحهم لتشكيل الحكومه في عمليه
تستمر حتى صباح يوم الجمعه المقبل ومن
المتوقع ان يكلف رئيس الاسرائيلي زعيم
المعارضه بنيامين نتنياهو بتشكيله
الائتلاف الحكومي بعد فوز معسكر باغلبيه
64 نائبا من اصل 120 هناك توقعات لا تتم
توصيه برئيس الحكومه حتى من الاحزاب
المنضويه تحت معركه وذلك بسبب خلافاته
تبادلتها هذه الاحزاب بعد اخفاقها في
الانتخابات